>> ♪ ♪
>> DO YOU THINK THESE MEMOS ARE
PART OF THE EVIDENCE THAT A
PROSECUTOR ROBERT MUELLER OR
SOMEBODY ELSE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING WHEN DETERMINING THE
PRESIDENT'S INTENT?
>> IT'S MY RECOLLECTION THAT'S
THE EVIDENCE THAT WOULD BE USED
IF THERE WAS A PROCEEDING.
THESE WOULD BE TO SHOW THAT I
WROTE IT DOWN AT THE TIME TO
BOLSTER THE CREDIBILITY OF MY
RECOLLECTION.
>> Bret: JIM COMEY TALKING ABOUT
THE MEMOS RELEASEED TO CAPITOL
HILL.
THERE IS AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT ON HOW HE HANDLED THOSE
MEMOS AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FILED A LAWSUIT.
THEY ARE SUING THIS LIST OF
PEOPLE.
DONALD TRUMP, JUNIOR, PAUL
MANAFORT.
ROGER STONE, JARED KUSHNER, RICK
GATES, THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
THE DONALD TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WIKI-LEAKS AND GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE NAMED IN THE
DNC LAWSUIT AND EVEN SOME
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL ARE
HAVING AN ISSUE WITH THAT.
>> I ACTUALLY THINK IS LAWSUIT
IS ILL-CONCEIVED.
I AM NOT SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
I THINK WE HAVE A SERIOUS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY BY THE RUSSIAN
AND THOSE WITHIN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
TO MAKE THIS POLITICAL IS
ACTUALLY THE WRONG THING TO BE
DOING.
I AM NOT INTERESTED IN A
POLITICAL TIT FOR TAT.
I AM INTERESTED IN GETTING TO
THE TRUTH.
IF THERE IS CRIMINAL CONDUCT
ENGAGED IN, HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Bret: WITH THAT, A LOT OF
NEWS.
OUR PANEL.
TOM WRITER FOR THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER.
AND LESLIE A RADIO HOST AND MATT
CONTRIBUTOR WITH THE HILL.
MATT, LET'S START WITH THE DNC.
SOME PEOPLE SAYING THIS IS A
FUND-RAISING CAM BIT.
OTHER SAYING IT'S AN EFFORT TO
GET PEOPLE DEPOSED AND CONTINUE
THIS THING EVEN IF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS WRAP UP.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> IT'S THE DUMBEST POLITICAL
MOVE IN A LONG TIME.
IT MAKES IT ALL ABOUT POLITICS.
THOSE OF US ON TV EVERY DAY TO
EXPLAIN THIS INVESTIGATION WITH
RUSSIA IS ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
MAKING POLITICS, THE DNC JUST
CONFIRMED IT.
THE IRONY IS GOWDY SAID EARLIER
IF ANYBODY HAS A 3W50E6 ON
COLLUSION AND RIGGING SOMETHING,
IT'S BERNIE SANDERS WITH WHAT
THE DNC CHAMBER SCHULTZ DID WITH
THAT NOMINATING PROCESS.
I CAN'T GET INSIDE THEIR HEAD
BUT IT'S A PRETTY STUPID.
>> Bret: YOU SHARE THAT OPINION
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WITHIN THE PAST FEW MINUTES, 7
MINUTES AGO, HE TREATED OUT:
JUST HEARD THE CAMPAIGN WAS SUED
BY THE OBSTRUCTIVE DEMOCRATS.
THIS CAN BE GOOD NEWS IN THAT WE
WILL NOW COUNTER FOR THE DNC
SERVER THAT THEY REFUSED TO GIVE
TO THE FBI.
>> Bret: I AM SURE HE IS TALKING
ABOUT DEBBIE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING THEY WILL
GO AFTER THE DEMOCRATS FOR ALL
OF THAT.
>> AND BOTH SIDES ARE WRONG FOR
DOING THIS.
YES, MATT, DON'T FAINT I AGREE
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT HERE.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT IS
LESS OF THIS.
THACHT LESS OF THE SWAMP.
THEY WANT LESS OF THE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS TO BE
IN THE WEEDS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THIS IS A
WITCH HUNT.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
LET MUELLER DO HIS JOB AND LET
THE INVESTIGATION PLAY OUT.
EVERYTHING ELSE IS A
DISTRACTION.
COMEY IS A DISTRACTION.
THIS LAWSUIT IS A DISTRACTION.
THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS ARE A
DISTRACTION AND THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDING IN THE WAY HE IS
THREATENING TO RESPOND, I DON'T
THINK IT HELPS EITHER PARTY OR
THE PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S POLITICIZING NOW.
I SAID TO MY GRANDFATHER
TONIGHT, IT'S THE PERCEPTION
WITH McCABE, COMEY OR THE
PRESIDENT OR THE DNC IS
POLITICIZED.
WHEN THE FINAL DECISION COMES
FROM MUELLER OR ANY OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, A LOT OF THE
COUNTRY IS NOT GOING TO BELIEVE.
IT THE CREDIBILITY OF
INSTITUTIONS AND THE CAPITAL
BEHIND US, THAT'S IS SUFFERING
HERE.
>> Bret: IN THE COMEY MEMOS ONE
OF THE MEMOS HE SAYS:
I EXPLAINED HE COULD COUNT ON ME
TO ALWAYS TELL HIM THE TRUTH
TALKING TO THE PRESIDENT.
THERE I SAID I DON'T DO SNEAKY
THINGS.
I DON'T LEAK.
I DON'T DO WEASEL MOVES."
OBVIOUSLY HE LEAK THESE MEMOS TO
HIS FRIEND.
NOW THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION
WHETHER THOSE MEMOS CONTAIN
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> RIGHT.
AND HE DIDN'T TELL THE PRESIDENT
THIS SEX STUFF, THE DOSSIER WAS
FUNDED BY THE DNC AND THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
AND JIM COMEY WENT BEFORE
CONGRESS ON TWO DIFFERENT TOPICS
IN TWO SEPARATE MONTHS GAVE
DIFFERENT ANSWERS WHETHER OR NOT
THE PRESIDENT PUT POLITICAL
PRESSURE ON HIM TO OPEN AND SHUT
THE INVESTIGATION ON MIKE FLYNN.
COMEY HAS AN AMAZING LACK OF HOW
HE IS COMING ACROSS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE LAX SO MUCH CREDIBILITY.
I THINK THESE MEMOS DO NOTHING
TO ADD ANYTHING TO HIS SIDE OF
THE EQUATION THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS ACTING INAPPROPRIATELY.
>> DEMOCRATS SAY THEY SHOW HE
HAS THE SAME THOUGHTS THEN AS HE
HAS NOW AND WROTE IT DOWN.
>> HE LIEED TO DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS.
ON TWO OCCASIONS GAVE DIFFERENT
TESTIMONY IN MAY OF 17 THAN IN
JUNE OF 17.
>> Bret: HOUSE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
ON THE COMEY MEMOS WRITE THIS:
THE MEMOS SHOW FORMER DIRECTOR
COMEY NEVER WROTE HE FELT
OBSTRUCTED OR THREATENED.
COMEY WAS BLIND TO BIASES WITHIN
THE FBI AND HAD ADDITIONAL
JUDGMENT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THAT WHEN I
HEARD HE WAS WRITING A BOOK, I
WAS HOPING HE WOULD NOT DO SOME
OF THAT HE DID.
TWO THINGS THAT BOTHER ME AS A
DEMOCRAT STOOPING TO THE LEVEL
OF THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETS
TALKING ABOUT HIS HAIR.
TALKING ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE COULD DERAIL WHAT HAS
BEEN DONE.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THIS MAN WAS
ANGRY THAT HE WAS FIRED.
MANY PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON WRITE
BOOKS AFTERWARD.
I DON'T THINK THAT COMEY HELPED
HIMSELF WITH THIS.
IF HE IS PLANNING ON RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
WEIGH INTO IT.
DEMOCRATS WENT THE OPPOSITE.
REPUBLICANS WANTED THESE MEMOS
RELEASED.
I DON'T THINK IT MAKES COMEY
LOOK AS BAD AS THE PRESIDENT
BASED ON THE PRESIDENT'S
BEHAVIOR ACCORDING TO THOSE